matt shoemaker coming off an impressive
start against the chicago white sox last
wednesday
making his ninth start of the season
113th of his career
two and two to galvest
that's hit to left center field
chasing it is larnick and he'll get
there on the edge of the track nice
running catch by the left fielder for
the first out
a little roller to third
and
donaldson thought about it they'll get
mancini at first and i think ultimately
the right play here there to get the
second out still a runner at second base
and santander up in this scoreless game
in the first innings
his 1-2 is golf by santander deep out to
right garlic at the wall and it is off
the wall
mullins is in to score and santander
continues his extra base hit assault
anthony santander makes it one nothing
o's with a first inning double
big pop-up behind second base simmons
out
ref schneider in
and simmons makes the catch to indiana
they face john means 28 years old 6-3
230 pounds comes into the sounding with
a 1.7 era
a 0.75 whip opponent spending 163
against have been dominant next offering
swing and a miss strikes out garlic on
the chain jump
on a one-two donaldson
hits one high in the left field
a lot of room out there for dj stewart
two up two down
strikeout to fly out to start the inning
and carol off with the ground ball into
the shift in wilkerson one two three
first inning for john means
one ball two strikes
and the pitch a ground ball tap weekly
near first played by kirloff and he'll
feed shoemaker underhanded
and matt catches and steps on the bag
after a lead off walk and led to the
oriole run in the first inning
right center field hit towards the gap
garlic calls for it makes the catch on
the edge of the track two down
and the yo one ground ball skips off the
mound right side this is gloved by
simmons he'll throw to first base and
shoemaker comes back
with a quick one two three second
payoff
got him swinging it was a changeup
hitters all around the american league
they go back to the bench talking to
themselves you know they're going i know
he throws it he can't pick it up
he's head over there outcast the only
one there means covers well and gets the
out
[Music]
rough snyder drives the ball out to
center field and cedric mullins
carol off with another try
and he'll take care of it himself and
now shoemaker had to leap over the bag
and oprah kiriloff's leg
it's been an interesting last five
minutes for shoemaker
galveston to right field that's down for
a hit mullins will hold its second on a
sharp single freddy galvez
continues his hot bat they always have
two on in the third that's that was
tough in itself
high fly left field hanging in the air
for learning
out number two
[Music]
[Applause]
and the pitch he does swing ground ball
to the right side from shallow right
picked by gordon throws to first and
that's out number three add the green
light grounds out baltimore does not add
on and strands two trevor larnick the
first in from the left side
as larnick swings and launches high and
deep to center field beckett goes deep
it goes and way out of here landing
inside the delta sky 360 sweep and
straight away center field
a long home run from larnick and this
game is even one to one tape measure
shot from the rookie he got every bit of
that ball
112 miles an hour off the bat that ball
was
destroyed
means ready 1-2
donaldson swings he puts a splitter
right back up the middle but it's to
stevie wilkerson on two cool steps sends
it to ryan mount castle
and a ground ball into the shift and
galvez john means living on the ground
his last five outs have come there
carver fouls one away
oh mount castle's gonna be there
garfield looked like he found it away
but
it hangs in play from outcastle
go ahead run 90 feet away for trey
mancini it has 41 rbis like you said the
next closest guy is 23. gordon behind
the bag
makes a nice play to end the inning john
means who's giving up back-to-back hits
on back-to-back pitches and that has
been it
yeah there's your fastball does that a
lot too so
his 45th strike out of the year means
with his third strike out of the game
initial offering ref snyder loops it to
center in comes cedric mullins makes the
head high catch and they're two gone in
this one one game for learning 3-2
and
oh called strike three take that one and
run with it john means don't ask any
questions santander drove in that only
run back in the first inning re-two
there he swings rockets it down the
right field line fair ball it rolls up
against the wall in right field
santander jogs in his second base he is
there with a double two outs in the
sixth and franco coming up long pause
and the pitch ground ball third base
fielded by donaldson he'll backhand it
come up on target to retire franco lead
off double strands him at third base
there's garlic struck out on the first
inning
[Music]
driven to left it's deep and gone
kyle garlick
with another home run to put the twins
up two to one big home runs against
two of the better pitchers
in the american league
the change-up elevated
jumped all over it to give the twins a
2-1 lead
high bounce fielded in right field by
garlic they're going to send the runner
here's the relay from gordon perfectly
on time
a great relay from garlic
to gordon
to garver and the inning ends first and
third now with two down for learning
in the air galves is there wilkerson is
there freddie takes control of the
orioles are out of the inning
stewart coming up to the plate as the
ground screw got the tarp off i'll call
it a stewart
and that one is drilled absolutely well
up to right d.j stewart deep into the
night and the orioles jump in front
worth the wait
two pitches
after a 45 minute rain delay
dj stewart goes fastball hunting three
to two birds on dj's third of the year
and now donaldson with the go ahead run
at first the tying run at third and one
out
fly ball center field
deep enough to tie the game coming in
from third is simmons
and the twins answer right away it's
three apiece and now a base sit danny
can give the twins the lead right back
garber oh for three tonight
down the right field line and down for a
hit into the corner
garlic will score
kiriloff being waved around throw to the
plate is not in time
a two-run double for garver and the
twins are back in front five to three
to left down for a hit garber is going
to be waved around throw to the plate
not fielded by the catcher cisco
garber scores cenote a second after an
rbi single and the lead grows to three
[Music]
sharply hit and off the glove
of galveston
and the twins will get another run with
sano scoring it was a bullet
simmons with a base hit to center
wheeling around third ref snyder
and the twins
with six straight hits after the second
out 8-3 twins
and that'll do it
nice win for the twins to start the
homestead letroy this team has been
kicked in the stomach so many times in
the late innings but tonight they kick
back it was a great all-around effort